today on the matt walsh show joe biden
unveils his brilliant new plan for
education he wants to add
four additional years of public school
your your children should be in the
state's clutches for 16 years he says
we'll talk about all the reasons why
that's a terrible idea today also five
headlines including talk of sending us
troops into haiti and a teachers union
comes out and says that we need more
critical race theory and education while
another union says that there is
no critical race theory in education at
all seems like a little bit of a
contradiction there and yet
and also yet another woman at a spa in
los angeles is sexually harassed
by a naked trans person plus our daily
cancellation where we will talk about a
recent
washington post article which informs us
that the word exotic
is now racist all of that and more today
on the matt wall show
you know if you're tired of throwing
your money at companies who
really would seem don't want it or they
want your money they just don't want you
they don't like you
if you're tired of throwing your money
in companies like that then start
looking for companies
that support you and share the same
morals and values as you
uh one such company is charity mobile
the pro-life phone company
and uh if you become a charity mobile
customer as i am and have been
for well over a year now five percent of
your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice
and that all that means is that when
you're when you're paying your bill and
you're
uh and you're doing that you're you're
also helping to build a culture of life
in america
uh as you support a pro-life phone
company but there are a lot of great
perks to come with it as well
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
there's no contract there's no
termination fees and there's no risk
either with a 30-day guarantee
you also get free usage alerts you get a
free app to monitor your usage
and uh all of that is great the best
thing is again you're turning everyday
living into effortless giving
for the charity of your choice so call
them at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with them
online at charitymobile.com everyone is
of course familiar with the old saying
about the definition of insanity
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting a different
result well
i think we might revise it slightly
where the government is concerned and
say that insanity is investing more and
more time and money
into an ineffective strategy hoping that
it will magically
become effective you can always count on
politicians to come along and say well
this thing we're doing doesn't seem to
be working
and that's why i propose that we spend
another five trillion dollars on it
nowhere is this type of insanity more
effective or rather more
more prominent than in the realm of
education as joe biden again
demonstrated yesterday biden tweeted
this
quote the the fact is 12 years of
education is no longer enough to compete
in the 21st century that's why my build
back
better agenda so terrible that's slogan
it's the worst slogan
probably the worst political slogan i've
ever heard build back better
anyway my build back better agenda will
guarantee four additional years of
public education for every person in
america two years of preschool and two
years
of free community college so 12 years
isn't working he says
let's add another four he unveiled this
plan in
more detail during a speech the same
afternoon at a community college in
illinois
here it is does anybody think in the
21st century
with the change that's taking place in
technology and
across the board that 12 years of
education is enough
to be able to live a middle-class life i
don't think so
and so the fact of the matter is we've
decided i've decided we should have
a minimum of 14 years of education 14
years of education which i'll explain in
a second
you know as a first lady i'm jill
biden's husband
but as jill would say she's a
full-time community college professor
while being the sec the first lady
she often says any nation that out
educates us
is going to out-compete us any nation
that educates us is going to out-compete
us
that's why i want to guarantee an
additional four years of public
education for every person in america
starting with providing two years of
universal high quality
preschool for three and four-year-olds
building
dealing on what the governor has been
doing here in illinois
and then i want to add two years of free
community college for everyone
[Applause]
and then i want to give everyone
uh free pancakes every single morning
when they wake up i think everyone
should have pancakes
we'll work out the details later but
everyone should have it there's so many
problems here that
it's hard to know where exactly to begin
biden says that 12 years
isn't enough to compete and quote live a
middle class life
his plan is then to add two years to the
beginning and the end two years of
universal pre-k which means kids will
start
at the age of three or four and then two
years of community college
he says he wants to do all of this
because kids should have a minimum
of 14 years of education now the first
issue
should be immediately obvious 4 plus 12
is 16 not 14. so biden can't even do
basic arithmetic and here he is trying
to
revamp the education system more
importantly
what does he mean by compete compete
with who
exactly who is my three-year-old
supposed to be competing against
well we got to get her in in preschool
so she can compete
what against two her peers well this is
all about the kids competing against
each other
how does it help to make them all spend
the same
the same amount of time in school if you
increase the amount of time
they're all spending in school then
aren't you just breaking even in that
case
or is she supposed to be competing
against children from other countries
is that the concern i'm supposed to have
for my three-year-old child that she's
you know that she is able to compete
against toddlers in china
where do we get this idea that education
is primarily a competition
isn't that a fundamentally grotesque and
bizarre and ugly way of looking at it
education is supposed to make people
smarter and more knowledgeable and wiser
a good education ultimately makes you a
better person note the the good
qualifier there a good education will do
that
but it's hard to achieve that goal the
goal of being a better and wiser person
if you're doing it in the name of
competition
or by compete do you mean simply that
our kids
ultimate purpose is to be cogs in the
corporate machine
you know that's their great calling in
life and more time on the government
education assembly line will better
enable them
to fulfill that vocation is that what
you're saying so again
what precisely are you saying what is
anyone saying when they advocate for
education as competition
and then in spite of all this talk about
competing
which sounds ruthless and dreary but at
least ambitious in a certain way
biden says that the real goal is to live
a middle class life
oh is that all now there's nothing wrong
with being in the middle class
most people are but since when is that
the fulfillment
the destination since when is that the
goal in and of itself
politicians talk about the middle class
as if it's all anyone should ever strive
to achieve
even though of course none of them are
actually in the middle class themselves
so just think about this for a minute
biden is arguing that you need
16 years of formal education
in order to simply be middle class
you need to be in glass from the age of
three until at least your 19th
or 20th birthday so that you can be
rewarded with a salary of 45 000
a year and an 1100 square foot townhouse
again there's nothing wrong with that
salary or that kind of house but
the idea that you need 16 years of
education to attain it is nonsensical
and the idea that such attainment is all
anyone wants
or should want is wrong and weird not to
mention depressing
biden says that um 12 years of formal
education simply isn't enough
this is something we hear a lot it
always it always rings hollow
in my ears i have to tell you because 12
years of formal education
is all i have and uh i'm doing quite
well i have to say i'm not a trust fund
baby i didn't start out with a million
dollars in the bank i didn't start out
with any money in the bank at all
and yet i've had success and now i'm
supporting a family of six on my own
with only a high school diploma to my
name
and i barely even earned that diploma to
be honest with you
am i some sort of earth-shattering
exception am i so incredibly talented
and brilliant
that i managed to do what biden and so
many others say is virtually impossible
i'd like to think so for my ego sake
when he says
when i hear this is like impossible to
do
i really want to believe that because
then that means that i'm
very special but i'm not
the fact is that a great many paths in
life profitable paths paths that could
lead to success
success do not require formal education
outside of high school and and then
there are many more which if they do
require uh some kind of formal education
outside high school require something
like a trade school not a four-year
university
these sorts of pathways and options are
becoming more plentiful not less
there are as time goes on more not fewer
professions
where the only thing that matters is
whether you can do the job
i can tell you that in my business
nobody gives a damn about whether
whatever paperwork you might have
all that matters is whether you can do
it whether you're good at it whether you
put in the work
and this is not unique
there are many industries like that can
you do it
are you good at it if you can
there's a spot for you if you can't
there isn't
waving a paper around and saying yeah
but i have this piece of paper
nobody cares that's the case for a lot
of jobs
but let's say for a minute that biden is
right let's pretend for the sake of
argument
that 12 years is insufficient that kids
are emerging from
their measly 12 years woefully
unprepared to compete
or even to be functional middle class
citizens of the country
actually we don't need to pretend that
actually is true in many cases a great
many kids
are coming out of their public school
education with no knowledge no skills
no idea what they want to do with their
lives or can do utterly ill-equipped for
life
having learned virtually nothing
there are millions of kids who went to
public school and in the end
have learned nothing they would have
been better off spending those 12 years
like in a jungle being mentored by
spider monkeys
there's a lot of kids for whom that's
the case and and
so we know that what is the solution
then
to send them back into that environment
for four more years
to do more of the thing that didn't work
to begin with
to invest more of their young lives not
to mention trillions of additional
dollars from the taxpayers
to do the thing that was already proven
to be totally ineffectual
no obviously not these are kids who
either will not thrive in any kind of
formal educational environment because
their minds simply aren't wired that way
i fall into that category
that doesn't mean we can't learn it just
means that we can't learn
like that i love to learn i just can't
do it if you sit me at a desk
for seven hours a day and you've got it
all regimented you say this is what
you're going to learn now and now you're
going to learn this
and now you're going to learn this i
can't learn like that
doesn't mean i can't learn
a lot of kids fall into that category or
these are kids who will not thrive in
the particular educational environment
of modern public school because that
environment
is horrible for learning which is why
only a very small percentage of kids
manage to do it
whichever the case four more years isn't
going to help
20 more years won't help and especially
won't help these days
when kids are spending large chunks of
their initial 12 years
sitting in classrooms and learning what
it means to be you know a gender fluid
pansexual
rather than learning foundational things
like writing and mathematics and science
and literature
if you really want to compete with china
then you
you'd get rid of the lgbt and the
critical race theory indoctrination
because i can guarantee you they aren't
wasting any time
on any of that in chinese classrooms
but all of that's a moot point really
the talk of competing of achieving the
goal of being middle class all of that
is
window dressing the real reason these
people want more public education want
to have your kids in their clutches for
longer and longer
is so that their minds and souls can be
formed
your children's minds and souls can be
formed into the shape
that these people prefer and that has
nothing to do with learning math or
science or history
the powers that be don't give a damn
whether your kid knows anything about
math or history or literature
whether he can write well none of that
is the point of education as far as
biden
and everyone else on the left are
concerned rather than cut back on the
lgbt and critical race theory stuff
they're making room for it more and more
and pushing real education
real educational subjects to decide
precisely because
these things are the point
your kids belong to them their souls
belong to them as far as they're
concerned
give your kids to us early they say
and we may not make them smart or
successful or competent
or happy or fulfilled but we will make
sure that they have the right opinions
and the right values that they become
the right sort of person
which is to say the opposite of the sort
of person
you want them to be that's the real
purpose
of all of this now let's get to our five
headlines
now we're checking in with my pillow you
know as you know my pillow
has a passion to help everyone get the
best sleep of your life
and uh they they will do that for you
all you got to do you buy my pillow
products
you're never going to want any other
kind of product but they don't just stop
by simply
creating the best pillow and they could
stop there mission accomplished
they've got a lot more than that my
pillow created the new giza dream bed
sheets
they look and feel great which means an
even better night's sleep for me which
is crucial
for anyone's busy schedule my pillow
found the world's best cotton called
giza might be guys i might be
pronouncing this wrong it doesn't matter
it's just comfortable when you sleep on
it
it's ultra soft and breathable but
extremely durable my pillow sheets come
with a 60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty
the first night you sleep on the giza
dream bedsheets you will never want to
sleep on anything else guaranteed
giza dream sheets come in a variety of
sizes and colors my pillow's making a
special offer though for my listeners
uh where you will receive two for just
one low price
plus free shipping if you want to take
advantage of that then go to
mypillow.com and click on the radio
listener square and use promo code
dailywire
there you'll find not only this amazing
offer but also deep discounts on all my
pillow products
so again call 1-800-951-7163 use promo
code dailywire or go to
mypillow.com use promo code dailywire
um okay i guess we'll i wanted to
include this
because it very much plays into what we
just talked about especially at the end
there of the monologue
uh the real purpose of education
which is to convert your kids
you know it's it's a it's a for for the
left public education
is religious education it's all about
conversion
and um here is uh it and
most of the time on the left they'll
deny that or they'll try to go
try to kind of use euphemisms they don't
want to speak directly about it and
admit
that yeah we want your kids we want to
convert them
and make them into the kinds of people
that we think they should be
usually they skirt around that subject
they're not going to be so blunt and
straightforward about it
but every once in a while they'll come
out and and admit it
and sometimes do that in the form of
song so
i got to play this with you for you uh
to begin with this is the san francisco
gay men's chorus
as they're called and uh they've
apparently been around for a long time
this is a a a video they put out on on
youtube it's
titled a message from the gay community
and uh anyway here's the message let's
listen you think we're sinful
you fight against our rights you say we
all lead lives you can't respect
but you're just frightened you think
that
we'll corrupt your kids if our agenda
goes unchecked
it's funny just this once you're correct
we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
and you will barely notice it
you can keep them from disco warn about
san francisco
make him wear pleated pants we don't
care
we'll convert your children
we'll make them tolerant and fair there
you go
uh that's that is
ultimately the goal now we we also have
okay we'll play this clip for you real
quick too because then
the song goes on i'm not gonna play the
whole thing for you um
but i think the creepiest part of the
whole song you probably thought that it
couldn't get creepier than that well it
does
here you go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh nothing weird about that a bunch of
grown men
saying we're coming for your children
what else do you need to know they're
literally they've put it in
song they're singing it to you we're
coming for your children
yep we are we'll get we got a whole song
and dance about it
yeah even in spite of this there are
still people
even people on the right a lot of people
on the right actually
when you use a phrase like the lgbt
agenda they kind of recoil they say whoa
whoa
yeah this is that's conspiracy that's
offensive
it's right there it's not for me it's
this you just heard it you heard the
song
they've got us they've got an anthem now
making it very clear
um the only problem with a phrase like
the lgbt agenda
is that it's it's it's this is all it's
redundant i mean the left's agenda
is the lgbt agenda is the critical race
theory agenda all of this is together
but they could not be more clear about
it they're coming for your children
and the way that they justify it is is
they say well we we want to make them
tolerant and fair we want to make them
open-minded
of course it's going to be our idea of
what tolerant and fair means
and as we know uh
this is not going to be universal
tolerance because they're not going to
be tolerant
we don't want your kids to be tolerant
of of everything we don't even want to
be tolerant of you
we want to turn your kids against you
no we want to be tolerant of of us
and the choices that we make and not so
much tolerant as
uh as celebratory is really the word
um all right let's
move on here a little bit of
international news this is from the sun
it says
the us could send troops into haiti
after the bloody assassination of
president
jovenel moise who was a gunned down in
his home
it's feared the caribbean nation could
be plunged into chaos after the killing
which has shocked the world and experts
have already raised the prospect
of a western intervention uh
can i say first of all i am not
especially shocked that something like
this happened in haiti
i admit i know nothing about haiti
whatsoever the only thing i really know
about haiti is that
it's not the kind of place i ever want
to be
but i can't be i can't say that i'm
terribly shocked
that something like this is happening in
haiti and what i can also say is that um
i have no interest in seeing any u.s
troops go to haiti
how is that our problem and i think we
have to be
outspoken about this kind of thing right
now
because right now it's all we're being
told is well there's there's talk we
might send some troops in
as the american people have to put our
foot down and say absolutely not
stop right there that's not happening
this is haiti's problem not our problem
haiti gets plunged into a civil war
unfortunate
not our issue you gotta figure that out
on your own
sort out your own problems
um all right let's move on here it's uh
here's an article so we've got two
things
which really seem to contradict each
other
call me crazy we'll start with an
article
on the oklahoma council of public
affairs website it says at its recent
annual
meeting and representative assembly
members of the national education
association
which is the largest teachers union in
the country
vowed to support and promote use of
critical race theory in the classroom
and oppose laws that prevent biological
males
from competing against biological
females in women's sports the nea
is the parent organization the oklahoma
education association and uh
oea members were among those
participating in the annual meeting
which was conducted virtually this year
in the 2019-20 2020 school year the most
recent for which figures available
um so on and so forth that doesn't
matter the task force's goal includes
increasing the
implementation of critical race theory
and similar material
in curriculum and pre through 12 and um
and higher education okay so
this is what they're saying they want to
they
are not only okay with critical race
theory in the school system but they
want
more of it they want to increase
critical race theory in the school
system
and if you're increasing it and you're
putting more funding
in it that means that it's already there
right
well this sheds some interesting light
on a speech given yesterday by randy
weingarten she's the president of the
american federation of teachers
another massively large teachers union
and uh
she has a very different take on
critical race there here's what she says
about it
critical race theory is not
taught in elementary schools or middle
schools
or high schools it's a method
of examination taught in law school
and in college that helps analyze
whether systemic racism exists
and in particular whether it has an
effect
on law and public policy
but cultural warriors are labeling
any discussion of race
racism or discrimination as crt
to try to make it toxic they are
bullying teachers
and trying to stop us from teaching
students accurate history okay so
critical race theory is being taught and
it's a great thing and we need to fund
it
we're told that on one hand on the other
hand it's not being taught this is just
in it's in law school it's not being
taught at all
well it's kind of got to be one or the
other and the way that they get away
with this
is that um it's it's kind of
it's kind of a yes and no to both to
both positions
because it's true that
you know seventh graders in public
school aren't being
they're they're not sitting the seventh
graders down and saying hey kids here's
this thing called critical race theory
and uh we're going to tell you all about
it there isn't any
subject or class called critical race
theory
that's not happening and that's how
randy weingarten gets away with making a
claim like this
that technically a thing called
there is nothing that we call critical
race theory which is being taught
directly to the students
that's something that's a law theory it
goes to law school
um and okay that's true but
no one no one is claiming that that's
what's happening
in fact critical race theory would be
much less of a problem i still wouldn't
want it in the school system
but it'd be much less of a problem if it
was actually
labeled critical race theory and taught
as a subject as its own thing
i wouldn't like that i wouldn't want
that either
but that would be far less pernicious
and damaging than what's actually
happening
which is that instead the the
fundamental
assumptions of critical race theory are
just embedded
into the education system
and into the curriculum and into
everything the kids are taught
especially when it comes to when it come
when it comes to any subject but
especially when it comes to a subject
like history
we're going to focus on the sins of the
white man we're going to pretend
that slavery wasn't basically an
inventive
slavery in conquest and colonization
these are unique sins
white people carry a unique guilt for it
there is this thing called systemic
racism and uh
and it's it still exists today
that's all of those things that's that's
all critical race theory
but they just don't label it that
and they are embedded into the education
system
but it is definitely there it is
it's underlying the entire
thing it's it's foundational now
critical race theory and also gender
theory is another
kids are there's i'm guessing there's
probably not a time
when kids k through 12 are sat down
and told hey uh here's this uh this
thing called gender theory
and it was first pioneered by a guy
named john money in the 1950s and 60s
and here's what he was all about
uh and and this is the idea that doesn't
happen
i wish that that would happen i wish
that they would tell the kids about john
money and give the
give the real history of gender there
but they don't
instead the assumptions the
philosophical assumptions of gender
theory are
embedded they permeate every aspect
of the curriculum and the education
system
but of gender theory and i think you
know the the right has actually had some
success
for a change when it comes to critical
race theory
bringing it into the public
consciousness branding it as a bad thing
which it is
mobilizing people getting getting
parents upset about this they're going
to the school board meetings they're
speaking out about it
it's been a huge success the right
historically has been very bad at doing
that
at mobilizing people exposing the left's
ideas
branding it in the public consciousness
that usually the left is
there that's their specialty
so in critical race there we've had a
lot of success there which is which is
great
something to be happy about um i hope
that next we can move on to gender
theory because
it's the exact same thing that's
happening
and we should it's that's what it is
it's called gender theory put the label
on it
it's also a very bad thing it's it's
even worse than critical race theory in
a lot of ways it's even more damaging
because here you're you're messing with
a child's sense of their own
identity you're depriving them of
identity
um and if we get to the point where this
is branded and we're talking about
gender theory
people like randy weingart they're going
to do the same thing they're going to
come out and say what are you talking
about we don't
we don't discuss gender theory in in
public school and in grade school that
that's
that's in you know that that's that's
something we talk about in universities
um but it won't be true there just like
it isn't for critical race theory
all right speaking of gender madness
this is something i want to talk about
even though i'm late to the game because
i missed some shows
uh you may remember the wii spa incident
that was we played the video last week
there was a woman
at the wii spa in los angeles she went
into the women's locker room at the spa
and there was a
man walking around naked and there are
kids there and there's women
and he's just exposing himself and then
she comes and and confronts the staff
and is very upset understandably
um she reacts like anyone should react
to that
and the staff says there's nothing we
can do so on and so forth well there was
a protest against the spa over the
weekend
antifa showed up things got violent as
they always do when antifa shows up and
here's how
nbc reports on what happened let me i'll
just read the nbc report to you
demonstrators clashed outside of a korea
town spa
on saturday after a transgender woman
apparently disrobed in an area reserved
for women
a few far-right protesters appeared to
be outnumbered by those favoring
transgender rights
police declared the gathering an
unlawful assembly in the afternoon
officers spread out at the scene an lapd
helicopter world overhead as
demonstrators shouted at each other
and in a few cases exchange blows
according to social media video from the
incident
the protest was prompted by an incident
captured on video and shared on social
media of a woman complaining to we spa
usa workers about a trans customer who
disrobed
and listen to this sentence here thus
displaying
her penis in an area where women are
nude
the incident occurred about a week ago
the workers stood by the trans woman and
said legally they cannot discriminate
against her
her penis and then the report continues
some of the protesters according to
images and videos from the scene
include included apparent q anon
supporters with t-shirts that mention
the term
pedo wood a baseless theory about a
secret cabal of satanist child abusers
in government entertainment and media
video showed demonstrators clashing with
each other and with police protesters
chance included
save our children another expression
affiliated with q anon
this is another thing where do you even
begin with this save our children
is a q a non-expression
you know i've been going to pro-life
events
for 20 years or more and save our
children is a really common slogan there
i didn't know that we were all q anon
supporters this is way before q anon
existed
so now according to nbc if you if you
want to protect children
you are a far right extremist
and even more specific than that you are
a believer in q anon because you want to
protect children
and if in general you don't think that
men should be disrobing in front of
women without their consent
then that's far-right extremism
but always remember the the people who
support this
who would type a phrase like her penis
for them it's all about science these
this is the pro-science crowd
well meanwhile um another woman has come
forward to talk about
her own experience getting sexually
harassed uh
by a trans person at this very same spot
and this woman who will play the video
for you
she she uh showed up at this protest
she's one of the far right extremists
but as she talks about in the video the
video goes on for like nine minutes
she's lives in los angeles she's always
voted democrat
she's very liberal she says she she's
attended she goes to pride parades
it's just that she doesn't think that
she and her six-year-old daughter
should be exposed to naked men that's
all
and that makes this registered democrat
gay pride supporter a far-right
extremist
well let's listen to her talk about her
experience uh at the spa she went there
with again her six-year-old daughter
and um they're in the the women's side
of the spa
and everyone's naked which is what they
do with these spas apparently
and she's at a uh she's sitting in the
hot tub
when a man walks in and here's her
talking about the story
we're having a great time we're in there
with other women when
a person i guess with a penis
and a beard came over with two
uh girlfriends they appeared to me to be
lesbians with tattoos and colored hair
and they appeared the three of them to
be
kind of progressive activist types
they came in with kind of an entitled
attitude
and they sat down on the edge of the hot
tub where i was with my daughter
my six-year-old daughter who was naked
and the
person with the penis sat down on the
edge of the hot tub
with uh just fully on display with
his genitals fully on display and so
me and the other women in the hot tub
kind of looked at each other
in the eye and we just kind of made this
face like what the heck
and uh you know we're motioning to my
daughter
i'm motioning to my daughter and the
women in the hot tub are like i know
what the hell
and um you know we were just
uncomfortable and i was trying to block
my daughter from seeing the
penis on the person with the five
o'clock shadow who was
not trying to look like a woman at all
and we got out of the hot tub
and i walked away and i thought it spoke
to like a different woman
and a woman this other woman said
you know they spoke to this person about
covering up but they refused
and i felt kind of horrified
so this is this is a man coming in
uh five o'clock shadow everything making
no attempt to appear like a woman at all
not that that matters who cares if he
did
you know if he wore a dress on on the
way into the uh to the locker room
before disrobing
that doesn't make it better
but it adds if it's possible to add to
the absurdity
and the grotesquery here it it just adds
to it
but now you could have men five o'clock
shadow full-on
men wearing male you know
masculine clothing making no attempt to
even appear like women at all
and they can saunter in taking off their
clothes
deep voice yeah i'm a woman and nobody
can object
or you can't object but it's not going
to get you anywhere and if you do object
you're a far right extremist like this
woman
but there she is with her six-year-old
daughter who's naked
just like she is a man sits down and
just takes
naked spreads his legs in front of a
six-year-old girl
this is straightforwardly
the direct sexual harassment of a young
child
by a by a grown adult male
and the left not only are they okay with
it but this is
something they celebrate this is this is
it's a wonderful thing
this man is living his truth or living
her truth they would say
so keep that in mind because when you
hear people
worry that we're headed to a point
where um we're normalizing pedophilia
okay you should know that that that's
crazy talk okay that is crazy talk we
are not heading to a point in the future
where we're gonna we're gonna see
the normalization of pedophilia the left
is not going to eventually
start advocating for and normalizing
pedophilia that that is that is
absolutely insane you should not be
saying that
because they're doing it now okay that's
not something that they're
they're going to do in the future it's
happening right now as we speak
when you can have a grown man take off
his clothing and get fully nude in front
of a in front of a six-year-old girl
and expose himself to her directly
and the left says that you you can't
even object to that
this is a wonderful thing when we get to
that point which is where we are
then we are in a spot where where
pedophilia is being
normalized they're doing it right now
we don't have to look down the slippery
slope and start
conjecturing and saying well you know if
we keep going down this slope here's
where we're going to end up no we're
there
um and and this this is what it looks
like
look the the normalization this is how
normalization
always goes any time of normals
normalizing any form of degeneracy
or evil
they're never going to do it directly
and they're never going to use the same
kinds of labels and terms that you use
to describe the thing
so of course the left was was never
going to come out and say yeah
pedophilia is a good thing
they're never going to do that they're
not going to use that word
that word is is forever associated
has bad association for everyone in the
world
they can't rescue that term so they're
not going to use it
but what else could you possibly call
this
in fact i'm you know i'm pr i may be
even understating the case a little bit
because i'm saying
this is sexual harassment of a child
as a man to expose yourself to a young
child of sexual harassment
i think it would be more appropriate to
say this is sexual assault
and in any other circumstance the left
would would
have no issue with that characterization
if this was a quote-unquote cisgender
male
who just takes off his clothes in front
of a six-year-old girl
i think we would all be able to agree
that is that is harassment is also it's
also assault you're assaulting her
but if the man um in his head allegedly
feels like a woman while he's doing it
then it's okay
all right let's move on
from from that for now one more story
before we get to reading the comments
this is uh well i'll just read you the
story
and i'll let you react to it however you
do and then i'll and then i'll let you
know what the correct reaction should be
all right um it says a peacock that had
been a staple in a california
neighborhood for years was found shot
dead
after someone posted a craigslist ad
taking out a hit on the bird
according to local reports the online
posting went up on june 13th a little
more than two weeks before the peacock
a nickname mr p or azul was apparently
killed
in humboldt county resident melissa
glass told the newspaper it's really sad
because he probably suffered for at
least two or three hours before he died
possibly more
glass said that one of the neighbor's
daughters had actually recalled seeing a
craigslist ad in search of a peacock
assassin
the ad which was first reported by local
outlet lost coast
outpost had appeared in craigslist
wanted section with the title
someone to get rid of a peacock adding
it wanted the animal dead by any means
necessary
the author claimed that the bird had
first appeared in the neighborhood four
months ago and complained about being
awakened by its calls
the ad read quote please contact me so
we can form a strategy to eliminate this
bird and also to agree on how much
you'll be compensated
um but glass till the night the times
that the peacock began visiting her
uh neighborhood six years ago and often
came by her house because it likes
spending time
with the chicken she owns um
and uh then finally this ad shows up in
on craigslist calling for an assassin
for the peacock assassin
and i guess someone actually takes it
upon themselves to
respond to this cry for help the bat
signal
went up and and someone assumed the role
of batman and came in
and vanquished this villain
now but now we're being told going back
to the article
says the humboldt county sheriff's
office said the deputies are
investigating the incident and that a
potential suspect had been identified
deputies said quote the crimes currently
be investigated are animal cruelty
and conspiracy to commit a crime
this i think is one of the great
injustices of of our time
arguably you have this hero
maybe two heroes taking care of this
problem
and now we're gonna charge them with a
crime for killing a peacock by the way
the only reason they're getting charged
with the crime is because the peacock
has pretty feathers that's the only
reason
if this was like a vulture or a crow
or even like a wild turkey some
ugly animal that doesn't have pretty
colors and they were in the neighborhood
and someone shot and killed him
no one would have a problem there'd be
no criminal charges
so the actual crime here is that you
killed something that was pretty
it was pretty and people liked looking
at it
and now we're gonna charge you with a
felony i don't know if these are
felonies but we're charging with a crime
now if you think that i'm being uh
that this is this is a harsh
to defend the assassin of an innocent
peacock i just why i went to youtube
because you know i'm something of a
peacock expert myself
you might not be um maybe the only thing
you know about peacocks
is that they have pretty feathers well i
want you i went to youtube and i found a
video that has the call of a peacock
just so you can see
and hear rather what this sounds like we
play this video
here's what a peacock sounds like
i don't know why this youtube video
exists there's actually a lot of youtube
videos of peacock sounds
[Music]
i don't know who all these weirdos are
who need you know 10 minute videos of
what a peacock sounds like
i guess i'm one of the weirdos anyway
listen to this listen to this
okay now imagine imagine this
for six years six years this
damn animal is coming into your
neighborhood
and making this sound at all hours of
the day and night and early in the
morning
and your neighbors are encouraging it
they're leaving food out they're petting
it taking pictures
and you were just tormented by this
sound for six years
okay we turned that off
uh you get the idea a really annoying
sound
even as even i mean all animal sounds
are annoying but this one is pretty bad
and he takes the initiative and now
we're going to charge him with a crime i
just find that outrageous
all right let's uh go now to reading the
youtube comments
um toothpaste juice
great username says matt was wrong about
charcoal wood chips are also a good
alternative to the devil's propane
yeah all allow wood chips uh you know
and as long as you're starting you have
some kind of actual
physical fuel that you're you know
lighting on fire
wood chips are fine charcoal propane
does not count
if you say that you're grilling out or
you're cooking out or something you're
using propane no you're not
if you have you might as well just use a
gas stove there's no reason to even use
the grill
edward says i used to be a teller at pnc
we're insanely carefully monitored every
move we
make every transaction down to the last
penny is tracked
so i agree teachers should be watched
our kids are far more important than
money
and deserve to be protected as such
yeah this is why i think it's just
common sense
you think about all the scenarios where
we use
cameras and usually we're using cameras
because there is
something being handled or dealt with
that we place a high value on
money our pets like we talked about
yesterday
so why not our kids
we see this this kind of double standard
or this blind spot not just with cameras
also with uh
with guns you know the same people who
object to cameras in the school
a lot of these are the same people who
who object to uh having
any kind of armed security in the school
well we can't have that
yet they have armed security at banks
they have armed security in almost any
government building you walk into
we use armed security to protect money
to protect physical objects
we use armed security to protect
politicians
you can go to the social security office
and there's going to be an armed
security guards in there protecting what
documents
pieces of paper and we won't use it for
our kids
so for all of those things money
documents politicians
we've got cameras we've got arm security
because we we really want to protect
these people and these objects but we
don't do it for kids that doesn't make
any sense to me at all
uh haley says i just realized that the
pink and blue alien thing in the
background has the exact same colors as
the bisexual pride flag
matt please explain yourself immediately
and stop with this
virtue signaling i don't
i accept this this is the aliens that
lived experience
and his truth and i'm going to accept
him for who he is
and if you can't do that then you're
you're banned from the show
uh sam says matt our nicu at our local
hospital had
video cameras that only parents could
access so many areas are implementing
more accountability school makes sense i
think covet was good in a sense that it
finally got parents to see what's being
taught
yeah um nikki's very another another
another good example our twins are in
the nicu for only about 24 hours thank
god but
yeah there's cameras there and no one
you have cameras in the nicu no one
objects to that
and also it's not as though it's a a
live webcam
on youtube that anyone can access
but you get a password if you're a
parent of the child and you can check in
when you want
why can't we do the same thing with with
kids you give
you give password to the password to
parents who have custody of the children
and they're able to access it that's
just
one of the measures you could put in
place to protect the privacy of the kids
we talked yesterday about other things
you could do
um let's see
finally or not finally another comment
says as a college history teacher i
would feel uncomfortable with cameras in
the classroom not so much for my sake
after all i already appear in videos on
my youtube channel and i guessed
appeared videos on other channels but
for putting in a sly little uh plug for
your youtube channel i respect that
but for the students privacy in a class
discussion students should be able to
respond to questions and express
themselves without
worrying that they'll show up on youtube
slash twitter etc and then get cancelled
for some nonsensical reason
i wouldn't have any issue with parenting
class syllabi or course materials would
you want your classes recorded or are
you only referring to k-12
yeah i'm only referring to k-12 because
these are kids
and this is also a government building
and that's why i think you need the
cameras there
but as far as not wanting this stuff to
end up on twitter and youtube all that
and all that well that's why you have
the pat
you have it password protected you have
the camera only trained on the front of
the classroom
you could even only give access to the
audio it could be an audio only thing
and then if there's an incident or
something happens a controversy
then you can go and maybe the the full
video will be released like they do with
with uh body cams
um and finally username hippie enigma
says i know you don't care but you lost
a fan for this nonsense matt walsh
well i do care hippie enigma that's
where you're wrong
i care deeply please don't leave me i'll
change i promise
don't leave please please
well that's okay we'll move on actually
i think i'll find i'll find a way to
to pick up and and move on with my life
even as we we
go our separate ways though it is very
sad to lose you
i've been telling you about when i when
i you know during my course of taking my
seven different vacations i've been
telling you about these marathon car
rides that i've been on the good thing
is when i'm when i'm the one driving the
car
i don't have to deal with with motion
sickness i'm not exactly sure why that
is scientifically but
that's the way it goes if i'm not
driving though
um that's when i get car sickness and i
get it bad and that's why
i am so grateful for relief band relief
band is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that's been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraine hangover morning
sickness and chemotherapy and so much
more
the product is 100 drug free another
great my favorite thing about it is that
it's non-drowsy
you can take some of those they've got
medicine you could buy but that's going
to make you drowsy
and you might not be able to you might
not you might not be in a position where
you can necessarily take a nap
and that's why you need relief band zero
side effects the technology was
originally developed over 20 years ago
in hospitals to relieve nausea from
patients but now
relief band is available to the masses
if you want to ensure
nausea is never the reason to miss out
on life's important moments
you got to go right now to
reliefband.com right now relief band has
an exclusive offer just for matt walsh
listeners
if you go to reliefband.com use promo
code walsh you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com and use our
promo code walsh
for 20 off well you may have heard
him discuss it a time or two uh possibly
it was easy to miss because i think i
only mentioned it like three times but
michael knowles has a new book out
and this one has words in it and that's
uh you know my second favorite kind of
book is the kind that has words and the
book is called speechless controlling
words controlling minds and if you
haven't picked up a copy now's the time
to do it the book
takes you through the origins of
political correctness and uh what
is what its rapid spread to american
society means for our future
it'll give you the tools you need to
understand and spot political
political correctness in order to stop
it um and also
you know another reason to support the
book and buy the book is that uh
it was the number one bestseller but new
york times decided that they're not
going to put it on the list i don't
think they ever gave a reason for it but
they just said no we're not going to
they can do that they're just going to
say yeah you know
number one best-selling book we're not
going to put it on the list um
that's another reason to buy speechless
so if you don't know the history and
relevance of political correctness
already
you're about to learn about it with
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available everywhere right now
and if you don't like making a trip it's
available on amazon and hardcover and
kindle edition now let's get to our
daily cancellation
have to admit i'm sort of jealous of
leftist pundits media personalities
columnists because they've set up a
system that makes
things easy for them and also it's kind
of fun i think the formula is simple
um and if you don't have any material to
talk about or write about on any given
day
all you need to do is pull a random word
idea action phrase whatever out of a bag
and come up with a reason why that thing
is racist or
otherwise bigoted it's like a fun word
association it's like apples to apples
or something except every word is
associated
with racism all you have to do is
explain why
uh explain why it's racist which is
where the fun comes in along with the
prophets
so there's a slow news day well no
problem just write up an op-ed or do a
cable news hit to explain why
i don't know sea cucumbers are racist or
why mashed potatoes perpetuate gender
inequality
or why the number 76 is transphobic
the sky is the limit and the sky is also
of course racist
g daniella galaraza food writer for the
washington post decided to play this
game
in a piece published this week titled
stop calling food exotic
now note how these titles never say
please stop or
maybe you should stop or here's why i
personally don't
like this thing it's always stop doing
it
you have no choice i have decreed and
now you must obey
as a theocratic fascist myself i can
appreciate that style but in any case
here's what daniella says she says quote
one of the nicest things about
afghan restaurants is that they appeal
to even the most timid of diners
mark and gail barnett wrote in the may
16 1993 edition of the post
your visiting aunt from spokane
washington can enjoy the adventure of an
exotic cuisine with the reassurance of
familiar looking food
the barnettes meant no harm no foul when
they put the word exotic in their review
of bethesda's sunrise kabob
but their presumptive anglo-centric
perspective on a cuisine based in south
asia
says more about how they saw the world
than about the cuisine itself
okay now pausing here the writer is if
you're a little confused
the writer is going back 28 years to
some food column
written 28 years ago in order to make
her point
if that seems like a hell of a reach i
mean it is but don't worry because she
also has random emails from readers that
she uses to prove her point
so you add together the emails and this
review of a kebab shop in bethesda
in 1993 and we've got ourselves a
full-on crisis
she continues quote after i wrote about
a seven-minute uh
seven-ingredient ramen in early march i
received the first of several emails
from readers complaining or gently
chiding me for
including exotic spices or condiments in
my eat voraciously newsletter
your offerings tend to be exotic foreign
cuisine that we wouldn't even order in a
restaurant and certainly aren't
interested in cooking at home
one reader wrote another complaint about
the exotic ingredients in some recipes
and asked if i could quote please try to
pick some recipes
featuring ingredients that are readily
available reading the word hit me like a
slap
and initially i wasn't even sure why did
they think the dish sounded odd or
disgusting
or were these ingredients simply hard
for them to find
the first problem with the word exotic
is that probably within the past two
decades it's lost its essential meaning
the second more crucial problem is that
its use particularly as applied to food
indirectly lengthens the metaphysical
distance between one group of humans and
another
and in so doing reinforces xenophobia
and racism
now the article goes on for many more
paragraphs explaining why as she puts it
the use of the word exotic tends to
quote
ostracize the other in the service of
empowering oneself
i'm not going to read much more from the
article to spare you the pain but i do
want to share just this piece towards
the end she says
she's quoting now someone she says i
have never heard the word exotic used in
reference to something that is white
says chandra d l waring professor of
sociology at university of mass
of massachusetts lowell you know that
exotic means other or different from a
dominant white perspective
because no one ever says i'm going to go
on an exotic vacation
i'm going to lowell massachusetts no one
ever says let's go to that exotic new
restaurant let's go to mcdonald's
now yes you probably have never heard
someone call mcdonald's exotic
that's because exotic is a word with a
definition and the definition
is quote originating in or
characteristic of
a distant foreign country mcdonald's
does not originate in a foreign country
it originates in los angeles county
and there are mcdonald's every 14 feet
in america so no part of mcdonald's
experience
could possibly feel exotic or foreign
except maybe when you bite into your big
mac and end up with some kind of foreign
unexpected object in your mouth like a
piece of hair or a
toenail clipping it also may be true
that you've never heard someone in say
japan
or vietnam or somalia describe american
things as exotic
do you know why that is well it's
because exotic is an english word
and they speak other languages in those
countries and have different words
to describe things that are foreign but
they certainly do
have some kind of word for that concept
and i can guarantee
they use it freely and nobody ever stops
to wonder whether its use is
ostracizing or offensive words like
exotic and foreign and alien
and different they are by definition
subjective
which doesn't make them wrong or
offensive it just means that whenever
someone is using them
they are referring to their own
relationship to that thing
a space alien is a space alien to us on
earth
when he's flying his big tic tac through
the sky while navy pilots
film it but he's not a space alien back
on planet zeptan or wherever
to him we're the aliens to us he's the
alien
the same concept applies in more
earth-bound situations to us
food from a country 5 000 miles away is
exotic
foreign maybe strange to the people who
live there it's just lunch
and to them our food and customs might
be strange
the only difference is that the
foreigner is allowed to make those
subjective judgments about
us while we're not supposed to make it
about them
and that's really what's going on here
right people like the writer of this
article they always tell us to
respect the lived experience that is the
subjective experience
of supposedly oppressed and marginalized
minorities but the supposedly
non-oppressed groups
and there's just one white people are
apparently not allowed to have
subjective experiences at all
at least we're supposed to speak and
behave as if we don't
everybody else can see the world through
their own lens and talk about things
describe things
label things in that way we on the other
hand are supposed to view the world like
detached lifeless inorganic robots
there's no exotic food only food no
foreign people only people
no difference only sameness our entire
subjective state
has been declared problematic
the only question then is whether you
care about these declarations or respect
the imagined authority of people like
this washington post writer when they
tell you to stop doing
these things and i can tell you for sure
that
i for one do not and that's why i can
say to her today
you are canceled
and there's the peacock again the
peacock is also
canceled and righteously so we'll leave
it there today uh thanks for watching
thanks for listening
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
president trump sues the oligarchs in
silicon valley a san francisco gay men's
chorus is coming for your children
and blm attacks the american flag check
it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]